Europe seems to be on a winning streak
so how's the US team gonna win well
we're gonna have home-field advantage
this time at Hazeltine in Minnesota we
have Tom Lehman as one of my assistant
captains from Minnesota
so hopefully the home-field advantage is
going to come through this time it
didn't in Medina a few years ago but we
were close as Darrin has been saying the
teams are evenly matched so it's going
to come down to hole in a few putts and
hopefully that home-field advantage will
be the difference if Tiger Woods gonna
join the team he is already committed to
be an assistant captain he wants to be
the first playing assistant captain he
and Jim Furyk have been out with
injuries they're both guys that have
committed to be my assistant captain so
we're hoping Tigers won back playing
here soon
to making a bunch of points and on the
team but at least we'll have him in the
team room one way or another so we're
excited about that
Darrin let's let's let's look back in
history at the miracle at Medina as they
called it you were a vice captain for
those who might not know Europe was ten
six down going into the last day and of
course they made that miraculous
comeback what do you learn as a vice
captain now a captain as a player what
does one learn when you come back from
such a such a level of being behind to
pulling back a victory an improbable
victory how can you take that into this
2016 Ryder Cup I don't know if you can
take anything from it I think
everything's got a lineup for a start
for to have a comeback as much as that
the American guys did it in 1999 at
Brookline come back from a four-point
deficit Europe and that Sunday a Medina
they just around the tables with on the
grains I hold everything and you know
you saw some putts go in that were
extraordinary that you never see as
frequently as happening that Ryder Cup
Sunday and that's what makes it so
exciting but you know my job as captain
and Davis is the same is just to prepare
our team as best we can and make the
guys feel as comfortable as they can be
and give them every opportunity to be
relaxed and play their best and and
that's what both of us are are striving
to do and hopefully you know there's
gonna be another sensational Ryder Cup
again I've got it as Davis back to you
though about golf you know we it's not
just Tiger Woods
obviously anymore Jordan speith and
others and we've got some great stars
now in the sport but why is it on a
decline here in the US well I think it's
cyclical you know we get on a roll for a
while and then we get behind but when we
when we lose we put more pressure on
ourselves the putts don't go in for us
on Sunday like Darren said they go in
for the other team so they have the
momentum they have that they're on a
roll and we just have to these young
guys like Jordan speith they have to get
a little bit more passionate about it a
little bit more excited and play with
confidence the US team is strong they
just need to play like the US team and
they can win Darren I mean Europe is on
an incredible winning run they've won
six of the last seven since 1985
Europe's what all but five you played
under samay yeah just to reiterate it
Betty I mean you played under some
amazing captains yeah what tips have you
picked up from some of the captains in
the past Montgomery a laughable I mean
you've played with them you've worked
with them who were the great captains
and what did you learn from them all the
captains have been different in their
own ways some of them have been very
much arm around the shoulder type of
captains or the ones have been a little
bit more standoffish and stuck to their
their opinions but I think it's a blend
of everything I mean the modern-day
golfer should be says a lot more I know
pampered than what it used to be
whenever we were growing up and playing
you know they get everything these days
so you know you get you they're just
different characters you've got to
understand them better you've got to
find out what what makes each one of
them tick they're all different and as
long as you can get your players onside
it's irrelevant what really the captain
does we're just a little small cog on
there and the whole scheme of things but
if you can get your your cap your
players buying into your thoughts and
whatever then baby and you've got a
happy team that's usually a successful
team